you
you
Bonz provide support for the body and
aid in its movement the place where two
or more bones meet is called a joint
joints may be immovable slightly movable
or freely moveable
a synovial membrane surrounds movable
joints inside the membrane synovial
fluid lubricates and nourishes joint
tissue such as cartilage articular
cartilage is a tough slippery covering
on the ends of the bones which allows
smooth joint movement
joints give the body flexibility
precision of movement and help in
supporting the body's weight
arthritis is any disorder that affects
joints it can cause pain and
inflammation
rheumatoid arthritis is the second most
common type of arthritis the joints most
commonly affected are in the wrists
hands knees ankles and feet it typically
occurs at the same joint on both sides
of the body it can also affect other
organs in the body such as the eyes
skin
heart
lungs
kidneys
nervous system
and digestive tract rheumatoid arthritis
is an autoimmune disorder this means the
body attacks itself by mistake in
rheumatoid arthritis the immune system
attacks joint and organ tissues here's
how it happens the white blood cells of
the immune system move into the joint
they release chemicals called cytokines
which attack the cells of the synovial
membrane
these chemicals cause synovial cells to
release other destructive substances
they also cause the synovial membrane to
grow new blood vessels and form a
thickened area called a panis over time
as the panis grows it invades and
destroys areas of cartilage and bone
inside the joint inflammation causes
fluid buildup in the joint making the
joint swell eventually without treatment
the joint space narrows and ankylosis
can occur ankylosis is fusion or growing
together of bones in the joint
this results in the loss of the ability
to move the joint there is no cure for
rheumatoid arthritis however doctors
commonly prescribed various combinations
of the following medications that when
taken together can reduce inflammation
and pain and slow down joint damage
these include non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs or NSAIDs
steroids and standard disease-modifying
antirheumatic drugs or DMARDs if
standard DMARDs aren't working doctors
may prescribe newer drugs called
biologics also known as biologic DMARDs
physical and occupational therapy along
with low-impact exercise can increase
muscle strength and help keep joints
limber
for severe rheumatoid arthritis that has
not been helped by other treatments a
doctor may recommend a surgical
procedure for example a joint
replacement procedure also known as an
arthroplasty may be recommended for
joints that are difficult to replace
joint fusion also known as arthrodesis
may be recommended
during this procedure the joint is
removed and the bones are fused together
with bone graft another surgical
procedure for severe rheumatoid
arthritis is a sin of ectomy during this
procedure the synovial membrane
surrounding the joint is removed in some
cases and arthritic joint may need to be
replaced with an artificial joint
for more information talk to a
healthcare provider